tengo entendido que esta situación se
ventila selim canahuati es un activo
líder de la comunidad palestina en
honduras su familia al igual que muchas
del mismo origen son empresarios que dan
empleo a cientos de hondureños y aportan
al desarrollo del fútbol la
participación de la comunidad lo tenía
para estima en la economía nacional ha
sido tan notoria como fundamental para
un desarrollo sostenible no solamente en
áreas industriales la comunidad
palestina en honduras es la segunda más
grande de latinoamérica después de chile
y aunque sólo representan el 3% de la
población lideran la economía de este
país porque se mete nuestro país en esa
situación es decir de ir votando a favor
de algo que rechaza la gran mayoría de
los países miembros de las naciones
unidas- honduras reconoció a palestina
como estado en el 2011 y aunque hay
incomprensión y rechazo con el traslado
de la embajada a jerusalén el gobierno
cree que puede mantener
con palestinos e israelíes estamos
haciendo los arreglos de edificios y
ellos aquí para también hacer
formalización en ningún momento
significa desconocer la pequeña
comunidad israelí del país está
optimista con las promesas de
inversiones
en beneficio de ambos de ambas naciones
que tienen mucho en común no sólo la
parte de cooperación de agricultura y
demás sino que hay investigaciones
honduras se convertiría en el tercer
país tras guatemala y eeuu en trasladar
su embajada a jerusalén